[Music]
hello and welcome back to playstation
grenade
so the next gen consoles are finally
here the xbox series x and my personal
bae
the ps5 so i decided to compare the ps4
user experience
to that of the new and improved ps5
to see what exactly has changed between
these console generations on fortnite
and i gotta say i'm impressed i'm gonna
break down everything i've noticed on
ps5 but keep in mind these are on xbox
series x2
you play wherever you wanna play no
shade throwing here
if you'd like to support me please think
about using code adamarrow in the store
but if not a like
would be much appreciated here's a ton
of changes you should know when you take
the step
into the next generation
so let's start with the battle bus and
likely the first thing you'll notice
when you see the island
are those new cloud formations
volumetric clouds
i never thought i'd be so happy to see a
cloud update in fortnite
but i am check out how the clouds
dissipate naturally
and i've also noticed there are far more
clouds when you are in a game on ps5
compared to ps4
even when it's the exact same match it's
when you see the whole map from the sky
that this
minor update looks phenomenal during my
tests i noticed that the night sky
was even more vibrant now with more
levels of contrast over the ps4 version
and everything just pops a little more
next let's look at those campfires
here's what lighting a fire used to look
like on ps4
nice looks good right well check it out
on the ps5 update
that is lit puns the smoke gathers and
the fire burns
in incredible detail the light given off
slightly illuminates the area close by
those effects were here on ps4 and xbox
one
but now on next gen lighting and
elemental effects
are insane
[Music]
next the storm whilst running around in
game i noticed the clouds as the storm
gathers in the distance and it's changed
i'll switch between ps4 and 5 to
demonstrate this
basically the storm has additional
colours which gather over time
the new purple sections really grab your
attention and make the storm much more
daunting as it approaches i've seen some
mighty fine looking
pink clouds forming where the ps4 keeps
to the og white and purple approach
i then decided to sit and wait for the
storm wall to move in
first on ps4 the animation we're used to
it's always been
quite difficult to know where the storm
starts due to the color being very
subtle
we usually look at a tree in the
distance and watch the storm cover it
with blue light then as the wall gets
close enough the small squares become
apparent
and the blue and purple colours even out
well on ps5
we have a key difference here the storm
wall now has squares upon it from
distance
right from the outset it's now easy to
spot from any place on the map
as the squares grow over the objects in
the distance
these squares then subtly fade away when
near and the wall becomes the same one
as last generation
here's a super small change i almost
missed completely
whilst opening a loot llama which
doesn't seem to have a new animation by
the way
take a look at the shield pot that pops
out on the ps4 it has a shadow
underneath
whereas now on ps5 this is a glowing pot
giving out a light source
how great is that super subtle but a
great update all the same
[Music]
next let's address the foliage around
the island when running around you'll
notice
far more blades of grass and plants and
stones everywhere
these are most obvious around dirt
tracks and near water edges
this really is part of a bigger texture
update because now the trees are much
more detailed and defined from the
quality of the ps4 days
of course the new gen stuff loads much
quicker thanks to those ssds
which means the render distance in game
now is monumental
which means now there's much less chance
you'll get the unrendered buildings in
the distance which look like
melted toast and this can also be seen
with the new volumetric lighting
look at penny's shoulders here look at
the edges of her suit
the light hits these sections and
illuminates the character and makes them
pop from the background even more than
before
and this is everywhere you go the
lighting on next-gen is exquisite with
darker areas more defined
and brighter areas piercing through the
haze
it's impressive work okay here's a very
strange one but i like it do you ever
frolick in the water
okay keep that to yourself on ps4 the
interactions with the water is quite
minimal
here i am jumping around like a fool
whereas on ps5
it looks like this notice how the
character interrupts the bubbles on the
water top and breaks through that flow
it's another completely pointless
addition but it's great all the same
the immersion this offers is usually
only available to high-end pc
players but now console gamers have the
same visual effects to enjoy
oh and this goes even further check this
out in shallow water the physics have
changed
come watch me for a look again these are
dynamic ripples on the ps5 and xbox
series x
whereas last gen is left without any in
the replay files on ps5 i noticed that
these
real-time effects don't actually carry
over and the water remains lifeless
it's a shame for those people who make
cinematic videos
but it just means that if you want to
enjoy this goodness it has to be in a
live match
anyway this is far too much talking
about me jumping around in water
let's move on on to something
less great now sadly those expecting to
see ray tracing on the new consoles
on day one at least will be a little
upset to confirm ray tracing is how
light reflects from
objects for the biggest example of this
we tend to look at windows with our
characters to see what looks back at us
on ps5 the reflections remain the same
as last generation
and if you look closely the reflection
is actually our character as seen on
screen
which is why you can spot your own back
bling in windows
so right now ray tracing isn't here but
it is on the way
i'll let you know in a map change video
when that happens let's go back to fire
again
i decided to burn down a tree to check
what happens
on the ps4 everything goes as planned as
you'd expect
but on the ps5 check out the flames the
flames are visibly improved and the
burning around the trees is much more
ferocious too
[Music]
other random things i've noticed include
bigger mushrooms on ps5
it's strange but true and check out the
cool added effect
to chug splashes on ps5 a particle
effect is added
to the splash zone check out the bush
here
the particles literally drip off the
edge wow
we really are in the next generation
dripping bushes
for our next treat i had fun with
explosives
and found some more changes here are the
ps4s booms and explosions
very nice but now on ps5 those
explosions have been increased
with once again the smoke effects really
adding to the intensity again
same with the grenades and other
[Music]
projectiles
the grenades in particular look way more
meaty now on next-gen hardware
and check out the trails on a rocket in
[Music]
motion
now that looks cinematic whilst testing
all this i noticed the new particle
animation when a player is eliminated
we are all used to the player
deconstructing and vanishing into fresh
air
but now on ps5 these have been once
again increased
everything is simply more impactful just
look at the detail of it breaking away
[Music]
another thing you may like to know is
what happens when we win a game
once we win on ps4 a few pieces of paper
ticker tape flutter around in the sky
and we are proclaimed vic royce well on
ps5
there is more ticker tape yeah that's it
strange but true i do hope
it's biodegradable
it should be noted that the ps5
controller supports haptic feedback when
shooting which means when you have a
sniper in hand
you'll have to press the trigger down
much harder to fire
it tries to replicate real life this is
awful for competitive gamers
but for those who want immersion you'll
be very happy here
whilst editing this i noticed another
subtle but impactful
change lens flare depending on the time
of day it's possible to see the sun or
moonlight reflect from surfaces
you may think that's nothing new but
just look how this horrible swamp
changes with a little bit of lens flare
added to the camera
i really should have shot this by the
ocean i don't know why i'm choosing
shrek swamp so there we have it 20
changes in the fortnite next gen update
some are huge like fire and water and
others are quite subtle like the
lighting and the improved render
distances
overall the game runs like a dream on
next-gen consoles
i can only vouch for the ps5 but i'm
told the xbox series x is just as
fantastic
anyway thanks for your time and has that
uh
thing stuck in your head because it
really has stuck in mine on screen now
i'm more of those leggings who are kind
enough to use code adamaru in the
fortnite shop these guys sent me a
twitter dm to approve their purchase
and i name them because they are
leggings tada
thank you very much for supporting me
i'm adam from playstation grenade you're
awesome
and i'll see you next time
[Music]